[موسيقى]
المقاربه الامريكيه الجديده للامن في
الخليج تكمن في اشراك عدد اكبر من دول
المنطقه في هذه العمليه الدفاعيه فمثلا
هناك تركيز امريكي جديد على اشراك القوات
المسلحه السعوديه والاماراتيه والبحرينيه
والكويتيه ودول اخرى من الشرق الاوسط مثل
الاردن ومصر وحتى اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
وهذه المقاربه التي تركز على دول المنطقه
تختلف تماما عن مقاربتنا قبل 20 عاما
والمقاربه الامريكيه الجديده تركز على
مجالين بشكل اساسي الاول هو الدفاع الجوي
الاقليمي والثاني هو الدفاع البحري
الاقليمي
[موسيقى]
المقاربه الجديده غيرت قليلا من اسلوب نشر
القوات الامريكيه ولكن يجب ان اوضح
للمشاهدين ان امريكا لا تزال قلقه بشكل
حقيقي من تهديد ايران تجاه شركاء امريكا
في منطقه الخليج وهذا التهديد الايراني من
وجهه نظر واشنطن لم يتلاشى ولا يزال يمثل
مشكله كبيره
[موسيقى]
وامريكا بدات تدمج بشكل متزايد القوات
العسكريه الاقليميه مع الوحدات العسكريه
الامريكيه والهدف هو تحقيق دفاع اقوى في
المنطقه كما تمكنت امريكا من تقليص قواتها
قليلا لتستبدلها بقوات شركائنا مثل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه او الامارات
العربيه المتحده او دول اخرى الا ان
اهتمام امريكا بامن الخليج لم يتغير
[موسيقى]